hi it's my pleasure to be here giving my
twelfth pie that I conference talk so
i'll start by with a brief introduction
of myself my name is james powell if
you'd like to follow me on twitter i'm
don't use this code this is a theme that
you'll see throughout this talk I I
guess at some point you get the
privilege of being able to give a talk
without giving a title so this talk has
no title in fact this talk has no title
no slides no organization no story is
just some code and some cocoa but before
I start some of you may recognize me and
some of you already kind of know what to
do when I say my name so I run NYC
Python it's the world's largest and most
active python meetup group you may have
seen me at an NYC Python event we have
events every week and we have large
events nights of talk every other
Thursday for about a hundred people you
may have seen me in August at PI
Gotham's a conference that I chaired
actually some of you in the audience for
speakers there is a really awesome event
I think we're gonna do it again in 2015
you may have seen me at a conference
that Iran independently of NYC python
and pi Gotham in march of this year
called for python quants that was a
conference for people like me who work
in the quantitative finance field if
you'd like you can see me next week at
the next version of this conference in
london and if you'd like to see me by
video this conference will also have
video tickets you may have seen me at
the very first PI data talk that I gave
in 2012 or the follow-up to that in
santa clara 2013 or in Boston or in New
York in 2013 or sometime this year in
London where I spoke in Berlin where I
spoke in Silicon Valley where I spoke or
today here in New York City so that's a
little bit about me let's get into the C
Python stuff so i take don't use this
code very seriously so i'm going to show
you some neat code but please don't use
it there is a message behind it it is
somewhat interesting and it can lead to
something productive but be forewarned
it may not necessarily lead to something
productive so we'll start with something
really simple all of you in the audience
should be able to kind of look at this
and figure out what's going on I have
some object called foo
it's of class foo and I type food up ass
uh-oh I spelled something wrong I meant
to type food bar and it gives me this
nice little attribute error saying that
foo doesn't have a bad because I should
have typed bar I wrote a module called
did you mean and did you mean you see
the code here is exactly the same except
at the top I import did you mean it adds
just this little thing at the bottom
maybe you meant that bar and how to
figure out what you meant it just takes
all of the all the attributes in the
door of the object and figures out what
has the shortest levenshtein distance
but that's pretty simple I think the
cool thing about this is how did I do it
and to really light that fire under you
I'm going to show you a little bit more
it works with getattr so I must have
done something kind of weird to make it
work better in fact if you capture a
reference to get at ER and then import
my module and then try this again it
still works so I must've done something
really weird because I'm not just
overriding get a tour and built-ins I'm
doing something a little bit deeper than
that in fact it works with all the
built-in types so I must be doing
something really wild it'll work with
all the built-in types and work with the
function type and we'll work with both
old style and new-style classes in
Python too so I must be doing something
really weird here for this to work in
fact you might say well he must be using
sis not accept took and it must be
catching the attribute as it percolates
up to the top layer so here's an example
in an unmodified Python to where I
capture the exception you can see it
prints out the exception and here's the
example with mine where prints that out
so I must be hooking really deeply into
C Python in order for me to be able to
insert my little did you mean no matter
how you try to access this attribute and
so let's see how I did it well the first
thing you might do if you wonder how i
did is you might do an LS on this module
you'll see oh there's a couple of C file
so I must have written a see module and
if you look into it you'll see well this
is a see extension module so he must
have done something a little bit low
level here and then see extension
modules in Python we know we have a high
in it module we have this standard
boilerplate and you see this little
thing called hook function and what
hooking it's hooking pi object get
better and it's replacing it with a
hooked peyote editor well it turns out
your C Python interpreter has all of
these standard routines for doing all of
these standard things so you call get a
door on an object and inside your C
Python runtime it calls pi optic kanata
you call length on an object and it does
pi object lengths and these are all
inside your C Python and some binary
that's running on your computer and what
I did was I wrote this little thing
called hook function and what hook
function does is it says I'm in an
extension module that's been loaded
after my C Python has started running
but I can visibly see all of these
functions that C Python exports because
module authors should be expected to be
able to use things like pie object get a
door or pie object lengths in order to
implement their own functionality I find
that part of the C Python interpreter
and it's somewhere in memory so I
unprotect the memory page because it's
probably in read-only memory and I take
my function which has a little no op at
the top and I move a little bit assembly
around to add one little extraction
which is a pop rack so I wonder what
that means and then what I do is I smash
it with some new memory looks like so
somewhere in your running C Python image
you have pi object kenner that's part of
the compiled C Python and I find that
and I just put in a couple of assembly
instructions to say no no no no we're
not going to run this code over here
we're going to run this code over here
and then i'm free to do whatever i want
and as you look through it i can do
pretty much whatever I want in fact in
addition to that so I have my own little
getattr here and it's the exact same
getattr that your pot you see Python
runs except at the bottom if you get an
exception it just calls distance which
levenshtein distance and it tries to
figure out what you really meant and it
can insert this behavior into this
getattribute call no matter how you try
to access it because you have no ability
as a Python programmer working at the
top level to intercept this code path
more deeply than I do so I have inserted
my behavior into your into your running
Python without you having to write any C
code or having to recompile your
interpreter do anything that you want in
this fashion this is an interesting and
perhaps powerful technique question is
where does it go and it may not go
anywhere it's not terribly
cool so let's take a look at maybe
another thing that I did because I did
that and then I got a little bit bored I
used to give a talk called see
embeddings of Python and I talked about
what happens when you how do you embed
Python into a see application so you
have some large runtime maybe a trade
system that's written in C++ or written
in C and you want to use Python as an
extension language you want to write
plugins or you want to model deals
really quickly in Python and you want to
interact between these two systems in
fact just today I was having a
conversation with somebody who said I'd
love to be able to embed Python into SAS
so I can interact with my data and SAS
using Python and I said it turns out
that embedding Python and to another
application is pretty easy there are in
those standard Python documentation a
very high level embedding and a pure
embedding and depending on what you need
to do you can use either the pure
embedding or they're very high level
embedding in order to get this done if
you look at my talk I go through some of
the steps and some of the implications
of one type of embedding or the other
but the question that dogged me and the
question that drove me to learn about
that was can i embed a Python
interpreter into another Python
interpreter because maybe I have a
Python too and I want to run some Python
3 code so I'll just embed a Python
interpreter and run it in this
subordinate interpreter and i'll be
happy so the first their first intuition
might be well python 3 is shipped as a
shared object so i have a python 3
shared object and this is in my Python 2
and i'll just use dlopen to open it up
and piyush lies I segfault and this is
something that we rarely see in pure
python code I've actually done something
so bad that the interpreter can't even
catch dear the whole thing just crashes
you can see I'm dumped right back down
to my shell so it turns out that it's
impossible for you to embed C Python
into a sea python because both your
Python 3 and your Python 2 or maybe your
subordinate Python 2 into your host
Python 2 they have a lot of global state
and when your Python 2 interpreter
starts it tries to smash some global
stage has initialized some things and
the host interpreter has already been
initialized and it all goes to hell and
you might confirm that to yourself and
say well you know i'm using a deal open
and maybe i can play with some flags so
I look at my man page for dlopen and
there's all these flags here and you can
try our TLD global and our tility
local and our TLD no load and all that
and it still doesn't work and you might
say well I want to prove to myself that
doesn't work so instead of writing
Python code using c-type source eff I to
try this embedding I'll write some C
code and in the C code I'll load up a
Python to using dlopen and I'll try
loading up a Python 3 using dlopen as
well and i'll try to link this and i'll
try and run it when i try and run it
i'll run into the exact same error but
if I'm clever I will scroll down one
more layer a man file and I'll see this
really interesting flag called our TLD
deep blind and what Artie ltd pine does
is it allows you to take a shared object
and load it in such a way that when that
shared object looks for symbols it
doesn't look outside of its own context
and when you do that you realize that in
fact it's not impossible to a better
Python interpreter into a Python
interpreter it's very easy all you do is
use dlopen with our TLD deep bind and it
works so let's take a look at that you
can see here this is a Python 2 and a
Python 3 running simultaneously in the
same process space they could share
memory they could do anything they could
interact with each other directly and
all this code does is it prints out the
version info and it prints out the
process ID just to show that I'm not
fooling you at all so you have two
pythons running in the same process base
but if you're like me you might say
that's not enough now that I've sold
this problem what more can I do and you
might ask can I run multiple pythons
inside a Python and it turns out you can
write code that looks like this that
creates maybe obstructive Python
interpreters and you try and run to
pythons and to to python 2s and to
python threes inside a single see
application and you might write a little
bit of code here and I were a little bit
of code here to make sure that there are
actually two independent or four
independent interpreters so with this
little code here what I do is I try to
import a little library import inner
tools and then I check is it or tools
and modules that's my way of setting
some global state and then checking oh
what's that global state set and I know
if the interpreters are the same then if
it's all just the same interpreters
being loaded then that global state will
persist over each one and if it's not
that global state will be independent
and when I run my code I see something
looks like this and I can interpret the
true and false for you the true means
that it er tools has not been loaded
insist on modules and the false means it
hasn't so you can see here my example my
Python too when I first loaded up the
global state is unset when I load up my
second supposedly independent Python 2
interpreter the global state is set so
these are even though it looks like i
have multiple python interpreters
running inside a see python that's not
the case it turns out that deal open
when you try to load a shared object
that you've already loaded we'll just
say no no you already loaded that one
i'm just gonna give you a handle to that
existing one and so it turns out you
can't embed multiple python interpreters
into a see application but i wanted to
figure out how but before i try to
figure out how i thought i've embedded
python tues and python threes can i
embed a python one in there as well so
on a plane flight back from the
conference where i showed where I first
showed the C Python interpreter I came
up with this I built a Python 1.5 shared
object and here you can see a an
application using the deal open trick
that's not written in C but it's
actually written in Python using C types
in order to use dlopen that embeds a
Python one a Python 2 and a Python 3
into a single interpreter but that just
doesn't answer my question how do I
embed multiple Python interpreter to
themselves now note I said how and not
why because there is no answer to that
second question well it turns out that
they'll open can't do it every time you
try and dlopen something it'll say
you've already loaded i'm just give you
a new handle and it turns out if you
read your man page like the good boy
that you are a good boy or girl that you
are you'll see there's nothing there you
can see this dlopen library gives you
Dale open it gives you a deal air gives
you dl sim but if your dogged in this
you might start reading this source for
your link library for your a dynamic
linker and in that you'll see wait a
moment my header files don't define this
my man pages don't describe this but
there's this weird Colin they're called
deal mopin I swear I'm not making this
up you have a deal open call and a deal
mopin call what the hell is dl mopin and
it takes this really weird flag in the
beginning called linker namespace
well it turns out there's another call
and you're in your link or if your
linker happens to be gold or happens to
be the one provided by lipsy which
probably for most of us running on Linux
is the case that allows you to open a
shared object in a separate link or
namespace and so you end up with an
example that looks like this this is a
see application that can use either dl
open or DM open to try to load a set
number of Python interpreters into a see
application here I'll try open and i'll
say i want three python interpreter and
you can see the location of all my
interpreter handles so all of these
interpret handles are in the same
location they're all the same and if i
just change it to dlm open now i have
three separate completely independent
python interpreter but the question is
what about global state are these really
separate so here let's get some yeah
here I'll try it with a little bit of
test code and my test code looks like
this I'll use a C library called locale
and locale can set some see global state
it's a library that is wrapped by Python
but it's a library that exists
independently of Python as a pure c
library and it has the ability to set
and get a locale so that you can do some
automatic locale translations and look
up so what not in my Python interpreters
in each one of them I'm going to query
what the locale is set to and then set
it to something else and we're going to
see what happens so got a runner with
command and you can see in each case it
will print out what the locale is and
then i'll set the locale and each case
the locale is uninitialized when i start
up that interpreter what this means is
not only are these Python interpreter is
completely separate with their own
completely separate internal global
state but any libraries that they load
themselves are also separate it's a
namespace after all it just happens to
be a link or namespace that is
completely undocumented nobody seems to
know anything about so what you have
here is an example of an ability to load
multiple Python interpreters and have
them do completely separate tasks
they're all in the same process space
they're all able to pass memory between
them you can control them centrally
they're not in separate they could be in
separate threads if you want to
they're not in separate processes and
rotten child processes are all in the
same process space and they're
completely and totally independent of
each other now what could you use this
for I don't know but it's pretty cool
and it turns out if you can do it in C
then you can do it in CF fi so here's an
example of the exact same code but
instead of using writing some C code I
write some cff I and I just take the
headers I just take the prototypes of
the functions and I just open up lib dl
myself because cff I doesn't give me
access to DM open because nobody gives
you access today I'm open because I
don't know if anybody ever uses DM open
and then I oh I load a Python too and I
could load multiple Python tues and I
have this thing right here that tries to
load a Python to recursively inside
itself so the Python to then tries to
let another one tries another one at
some point it'll fall over so there is
still one area that's not been covered
but you can see with this original
example you load ten popgun interpreters
into themselves until you run out of
space in this so-called static TLS block
and if you try and load 16 you'll run
out of link or name spaces so there's
still a little bit of work to be done to
maybe patch your dynamic linker to allow
you to embed multiple or infinite Python
interpreters in to themselves but what
this goes to show is you have this
process where something is said to be
impossible and you don't accept it and
you search and you search and you search
a new search and you end up finding that
it's possible and not only is it
possible but it's pretty trivial it's
just one call to one function with one
argument it's probably pretty weird
weird so I'm going to show you the last
example and this last example is called
the bang bang and let me make this ok so
this is a little bit of Python code that
we may be familiar with we have some
function f and it multiplies two things
times each other and those two things
happen to be constants ASDF is a
constant intense a constant and let's
disassemble this and see what happens
inside while on every invocation of this
function we're loading this one constant
loading the second constants of
multiplying them when ASDF never changes
and 10 never changes what we're doing
this redundant calculation every single
time we call this function so that's
exhibit a let's take a look at Exhibit B
we import the daytime
and we created date inside our function
and this is something that we often do
we have these literal types or we have
these constant values in our classes
they may be sqlstate query statements
they may be daytime objects and maybe
some rich object but notice that this
state is static few arguments will never
change and the date object is in this
case we can for simplicity sake consider
that it's immutable but you can see I
made a buck here because there is no
thirtieth of februari and yet my code is
not telling me this is wrong even though
it could look at this and statically say
well this is wrong it turns out that in
this case Python confuses or Python
combines the idea of scope as a
visibility of a name and the execution
context because what Python looks at a
statement like this it'll say okay class
foo so I'm going to create a code object
and at the end of the creation of the
code object i'll do a build class and
inside that code object will say I see a
function so i'll create a code object
for that and at the end of it I'll do
out make function and Python will line
by line execute this and it won't be
able to determine that date that this
invalid data is invalid because you have
to run it so this is one of the
limitations of Python that scope scope
is visibility and scope is evaluation
context are conflated what we'd really
like is to be able to say this variable
here exists in this scope so nobody else
can see it so that if we're looking at
some large function and there are some
variables inside it that those variables
are only using this function so we can
change them freely but we don't
necessarily want them to be evaluated on
every run of that function now one
typical technique that we might use is
we might do something like this will
create a constant value at the top level
and we'll say return constant value and
this is a very good approach except you
can see it gets ugly and as we have more
and more of these constants at the very
top level our top level scope is going
to be really dirty because if somebody
imports our module that has this and
they do a door on our module they'll see
all our Kant's it will put an underscore
in front of them to say well don't
really look at this but it's still going
to confuse them and so going to add a
lot for them to think about and it's
still not going to be that fast because
this is going to be a load global so you
probably end up writing it even uglier
to get some performance back you do
something like const value you make it
look
you make it local and then maybe in a
tight loop you say you might say
something would cost value with the
underscore version of it so what I did
was I added a little sin tax extension
to C Python and I call up the bang bang
because it has an exclamation point
which is in program rapport Lamson bang
and so what it does is when you add an
exclamation point in front of a
statement it compiles that into a code
object takes the SC encompassing Dakota
object and that code object has a
special name bang and when C Python sees
a constant Bank expression when it's
about to evaluate a function one scope
up what it will do is it will evaluate
it and statically store the result so
let's take an example let's take a look
at our original example here we have
this expression just as before
multiplying two constants together but
this Bank expression the semantics of it
are this value has this scope as
visibility of inside of F but as
evaluation it's evaluated one scope
higher so when we disassemble this
instead of seeing ASDF times 10 for
every time you run this function it'll
already have been evaluated one scope up
and we'll see just the constant value so
here we just load const of the value and
bear in mind that this is faster than
our example where we wrote the constant
out ourselves because load const is
always faster the load global constant
array look up global as a dictionary
lookup I told you is going to be some
wild black magic hackery but here's our
other example where we had this date
object that was a constant date object
and it didn't warn us well here we
evaluate that date as a constant one
scope up and so when we evaluate this
class instruct this class it'll warn us
immediately that this is a valid
constant so you can see here it gives
you a warning and that's something that
you might actually want you might want
to be able to add static checks to your
code to say when before this code is
actually run or before this helper
function is run in some tight loop what
I want you to do is I want you to
evaluate it and determine if certain
preconditions are met what you might
also want to do is you might want to do
this more richly than C Python already
gives you so pizza C Python has a
peephole optimizer so it'll already fold
some constant expressions integers added
to each other it'll already fold
but in this in this case we're trying to
calculate the roots of simple second
order polynomial and we as a programmer
know that if we give it fixed values
that this function is pure and the
result will always be the same so we can
add this bang expression at the
beginning evaluate at one scope up
disassemble this we can see restore just
the constant value because we know as a
programmer that we can decorate this and
say this is a constant expression it
only ever has to be valued once and then
for the rest of the lifetime of my
program that value is going to be the
same we can get a little bit of both
safety and speed from this and you can
think that we could apply this in some
very interesting ways so here I have two
functions one called fast path and one
called slow path that performs some
optimization and maybe the fast path is
requires a certain specialization that
the slope at does not require here I
have a helper function inside the
function I call and it's going to reach
into its closure and called the either
the fast but it's going to determine
what the best function is and it'll use
it in this tight loop here a thousand
times so my return value will be
whatever the best function is applied to
my two input variables well the
semantics of the bank expression say
that i can write it in this fashion and
i can determine on the creation of this
function once and for the lifetime why
running program what the best path is
and so if I as a programmer can say F is
only ever going to be called within its
use this fast path and that'll be held
for the inspiration of my program now
compare this to the tracing approach or
compare this to the inference approach
where the compiler has to infer for you
what the best types are the compiler
could always be wrong or your mechanism
for inferring could always be wrong and
so that inference mechanism always has
to have a safety valve where well maybe
I was wrong maybe these weren't ins and
some paths there and it has to add some
complexity from that and has some
limitations whereas in this approach
you're directing the directing Python
and saying if I was wrong about this
assumption it's my fault I'll change the
code myself and so you can end up
getting some of some very similar
optimizations that you could from an
infant proach without having to add the
same sophistication and complication
that you do from the inference approach
because you as a programmer can say I
know my data I know what's going to be
fed into it I know you can use this fast
path I just don't know until I'm just
about to run it
my data which path it is so that's the
bang bang I'll show you how I actually
implemented it turned out to be very
easy sell it bang bang not to be about
four hundred and thirty something lines
of code and it took me about three days
to do one of those days was spent on a
flight back from Pike on Spain and you
can see I touch a couple of different
parts of it only eight files I make
eight changes to eight files in order to
implement this and how did I do this
well I made one change the grammar and
then I ran it and I saw what happened
and I read a little bit here and I read
a little bit i had to kind of run around
to font to collect all the information
about how the different parts of C
Python work and after a while I
collected and when you look at this code
itself it's really really dinky I mean
all I do is I add in my bang expression
to the grammar and then for the AST i
add a section to set up some constants
mostly this is boilerplate i add my
tokens in here i add a little preamble
here where I say okay if you see it
evaluate it and that's it so you may
look at all of this hackery and you
might you might ask yourself two
questions the first question you might
ask is what's wrong with you that's a
very good question to ask and it's not a
question that I can answer but you might
also think two things in your mind and
the one thing that you shouldn't think
when you look at this is you should not
be impressed by this it's kind of
interesting it's a little bit novel but
it's not impressive in each case it was
really just the order of the first case
was five lines of assembly five assembly
instructions maybe even you could
measure the amount of code in bytes and
the second case was one function call
and the third case was 400 lines of
mostly boilerplate C code now if you're
going to tell me that you're horrified
and it's okay to be horrified and it is
it is more than ok to be horrified by
all this my underlying point in the
message that I want to convey to you is
as part of NYC Python and in part of
organizing PI data and events like this
you often are put into a situation where
you find people who have done very very
impressive things and not to not to
downplay the impressiveness of some of
the projects
I personally believe that examples like
this show you that technology that
programming that open source is
available and accessible to everyone and
I will close with a personal story from
my own life so I am a country boy from
Texas I grew up in Texas I don't have it
takes text I love Texas I came up to New
York to work but I'm a Texan at heart I
have never in my life ever sat in one
class in one spanish class and yet when
I was in Pike on Spain I could kind of
understand what's going on I could see
an exit sign and say oh that's an exit
sign i could see i could ask where the
bathroom was and how could i do that
well i was in an environment where I was
where I was immersed into the use of
spanish language and you could kind of
pick it up and it kind of you kind of
you you you absorb it after a while when
I went to university I went to
university for a degree in liberal arts
and my degree was in Asian Studies
before I started University I could not
have told you the difference between
thailand and taiwan and by the time I
was finished with my university I could
speak fluent Chinese and the reason for
that was I went to class every day I
went through all the exercises when I
would speak to the professor's I would
try to speak to them and they gave me
some feedback they said you know we
really Inc we really want to encourage
you guys to learn and every single
person in my class were all just country
boys like me from Texas we got to a very
very high level of proficiency in a
language which many people considered to
be impossible for an English speaker to
learn and how is that what's the exact
same situation as with programming if
you want to learn this stuff it's very
simple and it's accessible to you it's
out there it's just code and in many
cases even some of this wilds that was
only a couple of lines of code it's
there for you if you want it you have to
put in the effort you have to put in the
time and sometimes it may take a lot of
time and a lot of effort took me four
years but if that's something that you
want to do you should look at this and
should look at the stuff that you see at
this conference and say that's
impressive and I want to make that kind
of impact myself and I can make that
kind of impact myself and the question
is just like learning Spanish versus
Chinese Spanish is easy to pick up in
Texas because you're surrounded by
chinese is very difficult to pick up
because you don't have the same access
to resources two people to speak to two
books to movies so what do you do you
have to seek
out the same thing with all these code
examples some of this assembly hacking
is hard to find out to seek it out I'd
spend days doing research so how do you
do that for program and that's the point
of this conference and that's the point
of things like NYC Python num focus the
foundation that runs high data is here
to provide the resources to you to
connect you to the people that you want
to know the people who have the same
drive and the same desire to learn it's
there to help you do as much as you want
with this technology to fulfill any
ambition that you have because all of
this is just within your reach and it's
something that I find personally very
empowering organizations like numb focus
and locally to New York organization
like NYC Python are here to make
something like this look trivial to you
to say you know I could have done that
it's just a couple lines of code reside
to read this book in this book and to
know which book do I have to read and
you know who you need to talk to and to
connect with people who are maybe
working on similar problems so you can
throw ideas against that's the point of
all of this and this is why I like
events like PI data so much this is why
I love NYC Python this is why I love
this community I'm really really
impressed with everything that's been
put together here and I'm just so eager
for everybody of you in the audience to
just have the opportunity to to come to
the same realization that I have so
that's a little bit of code a little bit
of wild stuff it was my impromptu
untitled by that a talk I hope you
enjoyed it thank you very much
I think we have time for between zero
and one questions Hannah oh you can
already you can already is it a night
python that book you can actually even
go to temp mb to temp mb org and you got
a temp mb that organ just do pip install
did you mean it it pops up for you I
don't think it's very useful but the
really cute thing about that is since I
can arbitrarily patch any part of C
Python my bang bang hook I can make as a
module importable syntax extension it
could it could it could be developed
into something useful I'll say that
that's outside of my purview I'm here
just to do I'm explicitly here to do
stuff that you shouldn't find useful any
other questions okay thank you so much